außergewöhnlicher weise zwerg schießt
energetische blitze forscher der
university of york haben im rund 380
lichtjahre entfernten stern konstrukt
scorpius verblüffendes über den weißen
zwerg mit dem namen als kopie erfahren
klick zum science fiction
zitat als kopie wurde zwar schon vor
über 40 jahren entdeckt aber seine wahre
natur war unbekannt bis wir 2015
begonnen haben ihn zu beobachten
schon wenige minuten nach beginn unserer
messung wussten wir da passiert etwas
außergewöhnliches so thomas marge von
der university of york
wenn man von weißen zwergen spricht dann
meint man in der astronomie ausgebrannte
sonnen die das 200.000 facher der masse
der erde erreichen können allerdings nur
einen radius von knapp 10.000 kilometern
haben also ziemlich klein sind ihre
leuchtkraft ist relativ schwach
trotz hoher oberflächentemperaturen von
bis zu 30.000 grad celsius wenn ein
stern ausgebrannt ist dann besitzer
keinen wasserstoff mehr
der ursprünglich als energiequelle für
die kernfusion im inneren gedient hat
alles was der stern dann noch hat sind
seine helium atome alleine bilden diese
dann nach und nach eine kompakte und
extrem schwere helium atomkern masse der
stern dehnt sich dann immer weiter aus
ein roter riese entsteht bis der sich
dann ähnlich wie ein platzender
luftballon schlagartig rums
zusammenzieht im inneren des weißen
zwerges findet dann keine thermonukleare
reaktion der stadt bei der plötzlichen
größen produktion werden sämtliche
gesteinen die einmal um die sonne
kreisten vom weg abgebracht
nähern sie sich später wieder dem alten
stern an
können sie sich der gewaltigen
schwerkraft kaum noch widersetzen weiße
zwerge können also gewaltige energien
freisetzen scorpio geht hier
metaphorisch gesprochen noch einen
schritt weiter in einem intervall von 19
6 sekunden schießt der weiße zwerg
energiereiche lichtblitze ins all wie
die astronomen im fachmagazin nature
berichten sind diese pulse so intensiv
dass der optische fluss von ar scorpio
um den faktor 4 ansteigen kann die
tatsache dass diese pulse auch noch
einen großen spektralbereich von röntgen
bis infrarot abdecken macht den weißen
zwerg der sich damit eigentlich wie ein
neutronenstern verhält nochmal um
einiges außergewöhnlicher zitat es gibt
zwei theorien die vorher gesagt haben
dass auch weiße zwerge ein solches
verhalten zeigen können dass wir jetzt
genau so ein system entdeckt
haben ist höchst spannend berichtet
boris gensicke von der university erfolg
via scorpio solch gewaltige impulse
aussenden kann ist momentan noch nicht
geklärt eine schnelle und magnetische
rotation könne die energiereiche und
breit gefächerte strahlung erklären aber
zitat der exakte mechanismus der in ahs
kopien zum tragen kommt ist vielleicht
sein mysteriöses merkmal so die expertin
wir werden euch auf dem laufenden halten
und wenn euch das video gefallen hat
freue ich mich über einen daumen nach
oben
und natürlich ein kostenloses abo dafür
hier klicken und auch gerne ein paar
theorien wie es zu dieser breitband
strahlung von scorpio kommen kann ich
bin auf eure vorschläge gespannt und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran